crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
yeah you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know soccer star JUCO
above-ground cool goes better than most
Jay Larson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we go again
Oh
[Music]
the crab feast y'all know the Tuesday
another crappy that has jumper lows I
love I jumped up on you you came right
back down side it's like oh yeah check
this out I was like [ __ ] the crab fees
what I was like five stars let's up
people Jay Larson over here on the
Tuesday Larson comic on Jay Larson
comedy all social media October 20th you
got to go to jail arson comedy you can
pre-order starting around October 1st at
my website for the special hour special
I'm super excited about love for you
guys to pick that up take a look give it
a nice rating let people know about it
share it I'll be sharing as well so
please check that out when it's
available October 1st for pre-order
October 20th for the the full avail you
know what I mean
and I'll be at the La Jolla Comedy Store
the weekend after sickled October 6th
and 7th and all my in town shows I've
been posting on Instagram once at the
beginning of the week let everybody know
if you're in town and want to come up to
show up and doing a bunch would be great
to see you
mass I might be back there in September
at the end of the month here so I'm just
waiting to see on the thing but
otherwise sickle cell Ryan Sickler on
all social media Ryan Sickler calm local
shows here you can check my website next
week 927 I'll be at flappers running the
hour where I'll be recording September
29th and 30th for shows at the lawyer
comedy store use code crab but you will
get two-for-one tickets down there and
for any and all craft fees related info
go to our website the crab feast com
there are a lot of ways to help support
the podcast there are free ways to do it
there's merge their premium EPS and make
sure you follow the crab feast on
Facebook and Twitter we have some great
sponsors this week and every time we do
something with Harry's it's it's at a
perfect time for me because if you don't
know Harry's calm is a great place for
your all your shaving needs and I just
had an audition today
where I had to play this political guy I
can't remember his name but he's like
someone from history so I looked him up
online like watch videos of someone
that's you know I mean like it's a real
person not like everybody somebody from
history know if you're just like someone
wrote a script made up these people
they're fake people
Farren yeah what I'm saying thank you
right well I looked him up in the guy's
clean shave and everything I'm like oh
man I never shave you're very clean
shaven today boom baby when in have my
Harry's waiting right there for me
shaving cream feels like I come out of a
spa it's not like just some janky coming
out of a aluminum can it's nice coming
out of like rust bottom candy and the
razor is perfect it's I've said this
before the the shape handle the actual
razor is fantastic if you don't know
about Harry's calm it's a great place to
get a great shave at a fair price
why because over three million guys have
switched to Harry's how many people that
is that I've just said you know what I'm
not gonna just go to CVS or go to these
stores and pay for overpriced razors and
overpriced goods to guys Jeff and Andy
your ordinary dudes who were fed up with
paying overprice fees for razors and
started Harry's to fix shaving they
bought their own German factory with
over 100 years of blade making
experience to ensure the highest quality
all products are backed by a 100%
quality guarantee Harry's offers their
blades at half the price of the leading
5 blade razor selling directly to you
over the Internet
I mean we've seen this time and time
again people are just like no I'm not
gonna do this anymore and they use the
internet as a way to give the consumer a
better product for less money they're so
confident going to love their blades
they'll give you their trial shave set
for free when you sign up at Harry's com
slash Krab all you do is pay for
shipping
okay so claim your free trial off from
Harry's today the 13 dollar value for
free when you sign up just cover the
shipping what that includes is a
weighted ergo Namek razor handle which
I've told you feels professional 5
precision engineered blades with a
lubricating strip and trimmer blade rich
lathering shave gel which is like spa
quality and a travel blade cover to get
your free trial set go to harrys.com
slash crab right now Harry's Calm
crap are you hiring do you know where to
post your job to find the best
candidates finding great talent and the
importance of finding great talent to a
successful business is a challenge but
with zipper cruder you can post your job
to a hundred-plus job sites with just
one click then they're powerful
technology efficiently matches the right
people to your job better than anyone
else you know don't go hire the
neighbor's kid just because he's down
the street you want to do a solid favors
your business man that's why zip
recruiters different unlike other job
sites it recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them in
fact listen to this 80 percent uh eighty
percent of employers who post a job on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within one day they get
a quality candidate through the site
within one day all right they don't just
get responses no juggling emails or
calls to your office simply screen rate
and manage candidates all in one place
with zip recruiters easy-to-use
dashboard find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by businesses of
all sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
right now our listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruiter comm slash
Crabb that zip recruiter comm slash
Crabb
try it for free zip recruiter comm slash
crap
well something else you can try for free
is this week's episode every episode
every episode free to y'all and we're
excited about this guy we've had him on
before if you're in the podcast you know
who he is he's such a great storyteller
and we're excited to sit down and talk
to him about all that he's been into
lately ladies and gentlemen please
welcome back miss Tyra Shafer
Ari Shaffir all right Shaffer
so safer so much does your Ari Shaffir
browse in whose apartment mine yeah this
your third time though right yeah
because I didn't look towed hop yeah
that's right Wow oh you did it there but
I feel like those in life were there
right I can't really do four episodes
there I mean I only did four their riot
done a bunch before so me oh yeah full
charge yeah yes right that's right um
but then school yeah but then only I
feel like you've done this I feel like
you did too in my apartment I don't
remember either what I remember the back
have you been gained and then you had
said like oh that was a [ __ ] tough
sledding and we were like we want to do
it again that's right podcast because I
said that no that's what you tell me all
the time I've kept look at this once you
see something I have K I have to delete
text messages because my thing fills up
what have you seen his phone what is
that this is how gravity rules man
gravity - yeah holding you down so it's
doing okay so right so anything yeah for
sure
so I have to delete old text it's like
oh it's gonna it says your fault you
can't do it right you're going to lead
them yours because I know about it here
look at this I cut on yours boom this
thing from January it was good man we
get showing for her but all this [ __ ]
I'm like yeah I gotta get back on that
sweet thanks man I appreciate it yeah
it's saving a lot of space there I could
just text you once a day if you just
want to delete it well I don't live here
oh yeah that'd be great
you love that what are you doing after
this huh going back what do you like
better here in New York I don't like to
compare but New York do you I don't know
it's especially now before it gets cold
yeah so [ __ ] alive there you're gonna
get fall - yeah real fall and there but
in those seasons yeah I feel like
there's New York and then there's every
other city at least in the United States
I've been to Bangkok you know what I
mean yeah yeah yeah it is that that's
our America's big city
Chicago I'm sure - yeah I guess we have
a pretty big area but like
it's so [ __ ] cool and the people they
are like more interesting yeah notice
like here with the [ __ ] actors
there's such garbage listen man this is
great
well before we get into talking about
your travels actually why don't you
promote your special your podcasts well
I got oh yeah festival you guys do it up
top yeah yeah that's how we do man we
don't people cuz people probably tuned
out of this 15 minutes in you know I
mean get it in now not a winning record
on this yeah the podcast festival we're
both doing next the last last week of uh
October October we'll be there Friday
night what night are you doing yours
Thursday or Wednesday yeah we have a
live crab feast podcast which you should
definitely come and do October 27th
Friday October 27th the Tom Hanks club
actually done way more parents isn't
that alright that's a no oh yeah
remember he got the five he was the five
Club yeah it's like him and Goodman
maybe Steve Martin I feel like is Oh
Steve Martin Timberlake are short I mean
I saw the sketch let's can we talk to
your special yeah because I mean who
puts out two hours you know that when
someone does a two-hour special you
realize some of it probably 40% is gonna
be watered down and not worthy of a
special right so is it two different I
love how you did it man because you
always I feel like you especially when
it comes like storytelling and comedy
kind of break the mold of like what
anyone's doing and you've made it like
them go hand in hand was an adult and
one from your childhood right or about
wanting to have children young children
yeah less than my child adult is my
adulthood the children is like my views
on children okay yeah but that is a
problem people do get water down when
they do too much yeah so I had two and a
half hours of material and I cut that
down to an hour to house how do you even
work out to now how do you even know you
have two and a half hours are you going
up and doing two out like doing one show
one hour new on that set through through
Scandinavia I'm taking an intermission I
would do that a lot make sure it's like
a long show or I just be like which bits
can go in these are all kind of done and
then just be like as I'm forming like
well this bit doesn't really need to be
in there was there ever a time when
you're doing that show and like
Scandinavia where someone's like
yeah there was a fewer people like we
got help me on a babysitter I'm totally
cool good out here it's okay
I warned about which leads you right in
a not one to have [ __ ] kids yeah when
you were married before dude got kids I
have a daughter and a stepson oh yeah I
played football I forgot about that do
you
did you ever when you were married did
you ever think you wanted kids then or
did all of that make you realize now
[ __ ] that amount marriage kids the whole
we didn't want that no interested in now
I wouldn't even a thing we brought up
it's weird because you treated like the
marriage and wedding with such like
traditionalism you know I mean you got
married in the belly of the belly room
of the gunstore invites came through
text messages oh yeah 100% serious I'm
like I got another set can I come by a
fit like I just felt like it was like a
stand-up show yeah a lot of people went
in there going like is this uh is this a
work or what are we doing so how many
people got had to dream in America's
window to drink made a mom we do not say
a two-drink minimum open bar which means
I bought two balls of liquor that was it
it's all I could afford and a cake from
the [ __ ] Grove and a deli platter from
greenbots it gave me a deal because I
said was my wedding well how much was
how many people showed up 30 ish come on
come on that's see this what does it say
that says message inbox full delete
store messages question mark and then it
says Ryan Sickler yes or no and there it
goes yes this is so [ __ ] garbage what
why don't you skim what is that he
doesn't want emails on his phone he
doesn't want you Internet on his phone
he doesn't want that
listen it's great hey [ __ ] is worth
stuff I do too I understand that but you
also don't have to use the email or
Internet on the new phone okay but
basically you're using it for your way
if but you're very I would say you're
very discipline discipline is a great
word yeah but not when I had that
[ __ ] smartphone on me no one good
there's not a human being on the planet
that has a smartphone that isn't going
on the internet that's why
straighted who I have a cousin okay I'll
say you and I have a cousin she's she's
older I mean she's like 79 she has a
smartphone but she still uses it and she
I had laughed so hard her the other
night I called her in 79 yeah hello
and I was like how are you doing she's
like it's Ryan I figured it came up and
she's like honey I used this phone just
like the old school phone back in the
day I answer every call if I don't know
who you are I just hang up on you
really yeah she just treats she has that
phone and still treats it like a no-no
hello yeah it's just a number that pops
up she doesn't person so you're hanging
treats the [ __ ] iPhone like it's an
old-school phone you plug into the wall
and because they probably didn't even
know that's an option my buddy's dad
rolls flip phone he doesn't have
internet on it and he got a new one and
I go dude
ha he goes oh JLo I got a new phone and
I go really how'd you get that girl
ready to go in the basement to get it he
goes you know what I use a phone for
three things I use it for calling the
time and to calculate 15% for tip and I
go you know dude the new phones
calculate 20% for tipping so wait so
what made you say like why not just cut
this down and do one hour why do I need
to do two hours to 45s right it's 45 and
45 because I'd like to have a
through-line of my specials so I
couldn't think of it through line on
this one it wasn't coming together right
like that and then I was thinking of a
bunch of children stuff that was like
these things really hard tonight too
childhood at all I don't like to I do
that with segways and [ __ ] and then I
just hit me I was like nah I can I can
do too let's just do what I'm playing
for myself when it hit you did you get
Street like that you like nah yeah I
remember favorite war doesn't know yeah
and then I ran it by some friends what
do you think of this and they said like
you know you should change the
background to do something or change
your wardrobe make it look different
like yeah yeah yeah if access here like
the best comics in the world you can run
[ __ ] by ya know kid and it's [ __ ]
great and so then I just started kept
planning it and planning it and I can
really work hard on it
oh yeah why do it the old way and when
you're in New York how many nights how
many times a night II getting up depends
I try to take some nights to myself now
but usually like 15 to 20 times a week
yeah yeah dude if I do two spots a night
like last night I did the improv then
went over did your show yeah I leave the
second show and I'm like [ __ ] I gotta
get up right now because yeah you like
you can go do stuff at one show I did
two completely different sets cuz your
show is so so distinctive but if I'm
working on something and I go and then
you cook you come up with a new thing
and all sudden you see like I'll [ __ ] I
need to get on stage immediately yeah
and I've been telling Kate I'm like yo I
gotta like I need to be like grinding
like that because that's when you like
can start well it's ha yeah instead of
waiting for two days when you're like
that middle part felt weird and then you
wait two days later yeah but if you go
up to stand go up middle part was weird
take a subway think about it to the
state of New York get on you [ __ ] it up
again get back and listen to it they on
the way there [ __ ] it up and go back to
the stand-up New York go oh I think I
got all tweaked now then go back to the
stand again try it again but I okay
that's a little better then go to the
cellar close it out but yes yes yes
that's working now yeah that night it's
great and then you take the next day off
and day after that you get three more
spots yeah that's great it's great yeah
you cannot do that miss it no no no
maybe two I can get to hide like they
can get three but right that's not
normal no you're not doing that every
other night of the week no I'm not doing
that I did your show at the store last
night on the day before Jeremiah's show
at the store and I put my veils in I'm
like ah man I hope they double me up and
I think I bet that they were just like
oh he's already here but no there's
nothing better than when you can bounce
around and just do smile after spot
that's a Burt Bird said that to me when
a bill said that when I kept in here
because you use those spots wisely you
can go on a benefit out of them yeah no
[ __ ] yeah and I [ __ ] him up to before
where I was like waist just like thrown
in though I kind of hear a joke joke
well that was like the first eight years
of your career yeah pretty good
I love that Ari is like so trusting that
everything you say is like yes good and
then you should ah I'm so then are you
planning for like the next hour you're
gonna yeah you know what the three lines
gonna be yet Judaism
doing it all about Judaism though now
will you go to Edinboro have you done a
tomorrow at me over the last two years I
didn't do it this year but man do you
guys don't know I love it there
do you yeah first of all you can't be
sober all right I want to you sober no
no okay well that's great because I
drink every night to drunk and that's
thirty nights right like either
twenty-six yeah I had one day the first
year I was like I'm not sure I can't
take this anymore I've never done him
like this not even in college yeah knows
I'm going back to my flat that's an
apartment in the UK and I know and
they'd call it that okay great so I went
to my flat and I was like I'm just going
back I got there my roommate I hear Shaw
this Indian guy who you are he's in the
flat next door I mean he's gonna pop
over my parents are here come drink with
us and so we just sat in the [ __ ]
kitchen and got [ __ ] drunk off like
three bottles of wine with his parents
yeah never stops and how many shot you
just doing one show a night though I'm
sure night plus other people's like
little spots on other people's shows
yeah your own hour every night yeah it's
[ __ ] great and it's nobody there a
lot of people on holiday there in the UK
people will save it over there without
report and I got dude the line at the
Louvre when I was there you yeah I
really know you it's really - what are
we queue for this like you [ __ ] idiot
queuing line up you may throw my mind
the gap in for you oh yeah mind it okay
and that's cool man and now it's over on
Netflix you get like an overwhelming
response up it's crazy yeah it's crazy I
mean like the first day was more than
like just Twitter response you judge it
off that [ __ ] you know Instagram was
more than anything I've ever done and
then the second day was also on as by
itself more than anything I've ever done
and it was like that for two straight
weeks Wow
yeah every single day was like this is
the biggest like response day I've ever
had
yeah of anything for anything
and then the starters your phone
exploded I mean ello phone can't take it
can't take I can't tweet in this but I
can't check with it what's going on
can't check you can tweet from it you
have to like text it to like some server
that poro poro for you think you know
there's someone over twitter that's just
like man that Shaffir so let's talk
about yeah he's been pronouncing it
wrong on purpose
oh the separate intro we do you know how
long do I remember you were going on
your Vision Quest no isn't it I went for
a couple weeks in in Thailand a couple
few years ago yeah but I mean that was
great though I mean before we say that
or get into anything you went away you
didn't bring a phone to put my phone in
my drawer you had someone change your
password to your email I should I change
it I wanted to like change past one I
just went like this to a keyboard and
then I cut and pasted that I said it to
my assistant and I'm like that's my
password for Facebook Twitter and so I
just like change password of those
change buzzer this was like 38
characters long and then someone told me
gave it to them said I'll let you know
somehow I'll find a way to get in touch
with you at all arias yeah no email no
Facebook no Twitter Instagram and how
long a gun about four months four months
damn Wow
where did you go remember saw our Abrams
door and he just says like he just sent
us his [ __ ] and said he'll be in touch
[Laughter]
want to do a show in Nashville whatever
I forgot about I was telling people it
when you gotta go back like nothing
really maybe by late May but nothing
specific and I remember oh yeah they
wanted to do that at Nashville festival
and so I wrote them a letter I was like
hey if you still want to do from where
where were you when he sent it I was in
I think I sent that from Vietnam how
many countries did you go to a four
month six okay six yeah so they've been
more time in each country than I would
have thought I would also start off you
you gave everything away no anxiety
about it
tons of anxiety yeah
oh yeah you'd be like [ __ ] you all right
God but your I've always known you to be
a guy who just doesn't you don't really
hold on I mean like we've talked about
like how money doesn't mean [ __ ] to you
it's not the biggest thing and there I
like it
but it doesn't you member you offered me
ten grand once in a pizza place in
Hollywood Boulevard why because I was
[ __ ] gonna I was broke as can be and
you were like I can't lean ten grand and
I was like are you crazy like well at
least let me get the pizza pepperoni
please yeah yeah why not by the way
you're getting paid like a grand for
yesterday that's amazing yeah I want to
do the damn job yeah happy the next here
we go I'll text you so what was the
anxiety like what was like going off
alone getting off the [ __ ] grid and
nah nah I don't know how to do this I
went once to China on a tour so that was
all set up it's like you know how it is
people meet you at the airport and take
your places so I could walk around a
little myself and get you know get my
feet wet but and then I went to Thailand
how many bags you bring one bag like a
backpack got it in the yeah I got it in
the truck
I'll show it to you in the car don't
leave it is I want a cart my cart just
got broken into on metal here oh my Road
on Melrose when you do here club I was
doing the improv okay really they
smashed in my back window and took my
backpack
Julian McCullough's car just got the
same thing when I was at they the window
replacement place this girl was in there
same thing happened to her and she said
for the people in her street and I asked
the guy who was like taking care of the
cut like doing the car I'm like dude how
often he getting people in here and he's
like dude it's like an epidemic right
now mashing windows taking naps in the
hollywood empower me to step up and pay
for the lot of water yeah last time I
said hey man can you keep close I'm
going to re show and they're like yeah
be free valet yeah they don't charge you
the store no The Improv no used to just
self Park on Fred Segal yeah sure yeah
if you're so confident like my name is
sick yeah you know it's like I'm Jay
Larson right there and then you get
there and they're like I'm jailing like
you're already here man that's my twin
brother yeah you got it you know [ __ ] I
didn't know what was happening like that
that's happening yeah
45 litre backpack with a detachable like
[ __ ] look at him dropping leader like
I was an in Barrow from here what's not
here at REI you talking meters and [ __ ]
- I started - yeah I learned it yeah
yeah we're doing it wrong clearly yeah
the only the only one it's not like we
do it all where you do your way it's
like we do our way and it's for sure
wrong but that's because the Native
Americans that's how they measured how
we got it yeah
their feet we're actually humongous
cameto ours which is why it took so long
to defeat them
there were warriors and uh eventually we
didn't work - no I heard them I can't
come back like polio okay too far it's
not for you yes my [ __ ] got it back
back I left all right so why not like
did your parents know you're doing this
they know us going how are you mad you
got my salmon got matches you got to
give me a counter information like I'm
not going to no one's gonna really get
in touch with a sheik i won't let some
murders in like you for sure will you'll
find some reason to do it you're not
getting Mike I should say unacceptable
and I'm like if it makes you feel better
if my mom and dad do also will not be
able to contact and how did they feel
about it
uneasy yeah but I'm like she's like how
would you get around this is how people
got around that's right 10 years ago
yeah I mean after 9/11 yes is still have
people getting around like I can't
contact anyone right yeah so it's not
like that foreign I remember out like
this was like eight months ago I was
golfing and it was like the 14th hole
and I'm like ah man I haven't even
checked my phone cuz I keep it in my bag
so I go to check it and then I stop then
I go why do you need water check your
pack off and I go and I my head I go
well what if something happened to one
of the kids and then I go what would
have happened 15 years ago or 20 years
ago something happened the kids yeah
Kate's on it someone's taking care of it
what if something had my mom like
whatever it is I just don't want to know
what is happening and I left it and I
finish my round I found out that what oh
no yeah father past my sister the only
possible thing that could happen is
they're dying you need to go say goodbye
before they die yes that's the only
that's like oh you're like you I'm
willing to roll the dice exactly yeah if
I found out somebody just did dodge
alright died then all mourn from scratch
when I find out
got to be was in but hood it was like
three years later or like shows amazing
all right so you fly out of LA flew out
of New York New York to where first
Bangladesh Rukh Cotter transferred in
Qatar and I went straight to Myanmar to
Yangon Myanmar where is that it's
formerly Burma it's in between Burma
India
China's there Thailand's here Jesus cry
there first why there first because two
days before when I got my ticket wait
you don't you only bought to take it two
days before leaving yeah so you didn't
map it all out using today's technology
you just bought the ticket and went I
had two things that I thought they'd be
cool to say I have a question to ask you
we're gonna come back to but now that
you've taken the trip this way would you
then go back and do it again using
technology to see the difference in the
way it can be done
I like the way you can take a phone
these days and put it up to a sign
that's written in gender and then it'll
translate right on the screen for you
here's the bombing that would make it
easier that would cut down into your
adventurers considerably I'm happy to
converse with people with locals and try
to [ __ ] figure out a time it's so fun
yeah it's so fun and I get there were
times where I might [ __ ] I could use
something right now but the negatives
have not experienced some craziness what
about I mean how many white people were
there were tons tell the backpacker
trails in hostels yeah well of course
yeah white people's love to backpack
yeah most of Europe loves some Americans
yeah a lot of Canadians a lot of aliens
mmm they're the worst no the worst of
course the bad ones are the worst I feel
like Canadians and Australians though
are like adventurous and they get out
and go yeah like we're after college
they all go I went for four months
zapier
yeah gap year I was like we I told some
Canadian girls for 18 year old Canadian
girls they're like we're on gap here I'm
like oh we don't get that in America and
they were like nobody gets it you just
wait to go to college for a year yeah
it's not like part of the curriculum
yeah you just do it it's [ __ ]
brilliant you don't usually separate
from all your friends before you make
new friends go now yeah live life a
little bit see the world then go do get
one thing education forever we'll be
there yeah you can be
I had 75 year old people in my [ __ ]
classes when I was in junior college
just taking music and [ __ ] just to keep
their brain well that's crazy that's
what education is always going to be
there yeah yeah so this one girl was on
12 grand for a year she had 12,000
thousand a month thousand a month 30
bucks a day she was fine
traveling mm-hmm yeah because what
because it's cheaper wherever she was
going how much you saved up yeah
Southeast Asia's watching and she just
find a way when you have when you don't
have you find a way to have you know if
you have you know what I mean yeah
so I say to a hostile once for 12 bucks
and she was she was like oh we found one
for 7 next door I was like that's cool
and every little bit matters yeah yeah
it's just like so we re so you go there
first to go to me it was a nice that's
why I went that the weather wasn't it
looked at 12 day forecast for every
country that I had visas for didn't need
visas and uh it was nice yeah 12 days of
no rain Vietnam had like all right and I
was thinking go in there first but I'm
like I'm not going in a [ __ ] ITU land
and then what's the first thing you do I
stayed at the airport for two hotel
there
well you just I couldn't decide there's
a city bug on has all these crazy old
temples like Angkor Wat and I heard
about that was one of the two things I
heard about I was like should I just get
on a plane as I landed right there and
go to bug on there's an hour and half
away hour away something like that light
and light light and they leave in every
45 minutes and I was like shite and I
just stood there I make sure I do
they're very vague it sounds like
they're very probably have what plane
like
I mean I'm getting a little anxiety just
thinking about like being in that if it
was me like [ __ ] where am I going what's
yeah I don't and then I'm like let me
get my feet wet and Yangon Rangoon heard
of Rangoon megadriving doing all the
time oh there we go they renamed it
Yangon okay cuz the [ __ ] army killed
too many people so they were like we
gonna get a name change and so then I
was like get my feet wet and I get
comfortable this city in the big city
that's their New York and so I was like
yeah I'll do that I took a cab found a
hotel there like 20 50 bucks a night I'm
like this ain't gonna work for [ __ ]
however many months yeah
oh my god I think Sunday night well this
is just the first night but I don't know
how long I'm going on how much was 250
250 and I was like no yeah anything she
be like this place down the street for
150 I'm like I mean like cheaper and
they're real helpful they're like yeah
here they were torturing me a little map
[Laughter]
it's got one granule yeah
checked in a little bit they had a
computer I got on the computer looked up
where some hostels were and then I'm
hostels all the way yeah but you didn't
have any like let's go my god alright or
anything so you are using technology
you're just not bringing it with you
here and there when you could oh no I
did find had this little burner phone
this burner smartphone that I found that
I got an Edinburgh like 20 pounds so for
like flights and [ __ ] I'm gonna crack
that open and yeah and and and make like
kayak flights if I had to go to like a
new country and you never before you
left you didn't research anything about
if anyone was in war or conflict or
anything going on or hey right now it's
not a good Maginot there are a lot of
countries that they tell you hey
Americans right now it's not a good time
for you to [ __ ] go there you know a
little bit these Timor was like though
yeah and then I talked to my
half-brother he's our captain in the
army and he was like do not go to East
Timor and if you have to go the Capitals
Dilli it looks like this like the
Capitals there do not go any further
east than really do not it is not safe
and I was like and this guy's been
everywhere so I was like alright stay
away from you in what country is that
he's two more two more left a I'm gonna
say it just civil war that fees fan hits
us up all the time and yes howdy same or
less than Timor Leste he's got a ft CF
sticker on the sign there and everything
he's in the middle
he's over no way he'll hear this and hit
me up I'm sure of it Madeline for life
did Timor Leste it depends on told us
the blind crippled and crazy story I
said that he's the one that sends this
he's got a sticker over there on Timor
Leste where is that it's it's it's broke
off from Indonesia so if you get like
all these islands of Indonesia huh and
then they have East Timor and West Timor
split down the middle it's one of the
most eastern parts of and they have
Papua New Guinea over here but like yeah
so this East Timor broke off they
usually Portuguese then Indonesia took
him over and then they're just all that
deal he's like right here so he's like
nothing that way and what is it civil
war that's going on it was civil war
yeah I was a lot actually
so it was like stay away I was like
alright fine so that's one country so
you start starting Myanmar
there'll be there for a week and how
many days you there a week no I spent
four days in Yangon and I was like I'm
ready to go to but God did anything
crazy or what's the most interesting
that happened while Gary crazy would
right ok so you get the food what are
you eating street food the street food
culture in in Myanmar is out of this
world
really everywhere everywhere there's
somebody [ __ ] chopping up stuff you
don't even know what it is you point
give him the one and they're like one
three I don't know I don't know what's
an order you try to like hand motion up
you give him your biggest bill because
you're only given like a like a fifty
whatever and have to go that's not
nearly enough yeah look absolutely just
give him like the thousand shot and then
they do give you the change like cool
cool cool cool
instead of having negotiate yeah they're
pretty honest in Myanmar and then uh he
eats crazy Street food walk around and
I'm incredibly lonely at this point yeah
cuz I don't know anybody I can't contact
anybody and I was like I [ __ ] up
this was what day - they - yeah I [ __ ]
up back regret on yeah but I mean it's
like anything you got a [ __ ] power
through it well I was like I don't have
to power through it I can just go home
what have I done
no big deal yeah didn't really tell how
many people I'm going I can just go home
that's when you came back just children
no but I let Duncan stay in my apartment
for January because he was moving to
[ __ ] in New York so I was like Oh
perfect timing
take my apartment so I was like I
would've had to tell him I was like let
me give it another let me give it longer
and the next day I met a cool guy yeah
and a lady
where were they merican one was from not
one is a English guy and other ones that
lady was German and she was the first
one I met and she was a traveler she was
like I stay in places where you got a
mime out like sleep me sleep I she's
like I've slept on beaches I crossed
land borders and I'm like [ __ ] ladies
yeah this is like I'm one of the five
countries it was nuts she was she knew
it she was like I'm sick today so I'm
Stan should have been gone yesterday how
long would she had she been traveling
for I I don't know probably if I'm
remembering right like four to six
months he's already had been gone for a
while yeah and then I learned a little
from her and then I got on a train and
then I can I start taking thirteen
hour-long buses - how do you know where
to go if you can't read so at hostels
they'll tell you a little bit like you
got to get here sometimes I make phone
calls for you the people behind the
counter but I'll get you a ticket
otherwise he's gonna go yeah you got to
go like I'm going to see Paul you see
the CEPA and you're like seat belt want
and like this and you're like alright
kinda money
numbers are the same use the same like
digits for that you know 700 or
something it's on a sign and were you
ever using your credit card yeah yeah I
had I had two credit cards in case one
got lost
yeah you could take out money it's not
that for like you know there's ATMs
everywhere yeah maybe not Cuba I've
heard but like almost everywhere alright
so your second stop is where you went to
where so I went to this town called
Mandalay and then I was gonna take this
long train to Seabright Bay what great
Bay Bay Bay there's a name
oh yeah beautiful but that train was
full in the window-seat he's so I was
like [ __ ] I go to be gone I'll go to
that City and then I went there wait
because there was no window seat you'd
like I'll go somewhere else the point of
this train was like a 40 hour long
training Yoda see some giant aqueduct
that's there from colonial times you
specs like one of the things it's cool
to see so if I go no one who sees I'm
like bug this then so I put my stuff
down for two hours and I'm [ __ ]
another took a another bus to [ __ ]
bygone before yeah my compression pants
on walking up and down that guy and they
crank the AC to a level you wouldn't
think possible you can face your breath
makes your hips feel yeah with shorts
and a t-shirt because and I start to go
to the bus I took my [ __ ] my trusty
wish my detachable back out he goes whoa
no no he looked looked at my clothes no
no I was like oh I showed him jeans and
a sweatshirt okay we're doing gonna be
on that 13 hour bus for even that's a
shirt and it's 92 degrees outside yeah
so you're like this should be fine but
they cranked it so much to give you a
blanket
and they give you a bag this isn't the
bus is it a new blank and unwrapped or
they just throwing you I'm buying now it
seems it didn't seem dirty dirty but it
wasn't it was ready yeah yeah yo you put
all that [ __ ] away pretty fast
it took me you have yeah I don't care if
these are bloodstains on the right
blanket I'm not missing it yeah yeah
yeah they cranked it so and then you get
out like they make stops when you fall
asleep every two hours like stop let's
eat like I don't you just want to sleep
like everybody off now they make you get
all yeah in their language and Burmese I
usually tired but now you're warming up
it's [ __ ] 2 a.m. and it's [ __ ] at
least warm oh my god that's man and no
one [ __ ] with you tried to rob you
swindle you some guy tried to jerk me
off once once I were up to that on the
train on their bloody blanket dude
trying to really Google Translate on his
phone he is he was like what's his
[ __ ] local what's this foreigner
doing on a local long local
when I bus yeah everybody thought you
were comical when you're white out there
they're like look at you look at you do
people took pictures with you those four
Canadian girls we had a line at some
point at this temple in bug on there's a
line of people like I got picture Nazca
it was just like couple of superstars
I mean like 13 14 deep one lady went
back in line
she like sweet boy and she's like no I
saw you
somebody hold their baby once and I'm
like for what because I want to take a
picture with you my baby he just took a
picture because I guess I already
looking the Canadian cheese like they
saw my Netflix for is out yeah yeah they
like he's gonna want to see this when he
grows up he's gonna want to know him
that was awakened yeah what kind of
that's a lie I don't know about use this
and no I did is no white yeah and then I
stayed in Myanmar for like almost three
weeks maybe over three weeks so one
place for almost four not long we have
all four months yeah and were you like
so you know you say now like when you're
in New York your take nights off to
yourself would you like taking nights
off from like doing tours [ __ ] to just
be like hey let's do what a local does
go to a cafe eat ghost you know well it
got more and more I should got more and
more that as it went on yeah but every
night's a night off like you can just
say no I'm not doing that at any point
no one's like this is the only thing to
do this a bunch of stuff to do this
tourist [ __ ] but there's also just like
fun things in Yangon they had the circle
bus just a regular commuter bus a train
excuse me it goes all the way outside
the city then all the way back and just
a big circle and locals take it and it's
just like it's a cool thing to see
ladies coming with [ __ ] food in their
heads and sell it and sell beers and
[ __ ] and just like I just hung out with
that like big red this guy from that guy
from England we're just like I know did
it for like four hours
what up and you did no stand-up at all
or did you know stand-up i Wetzel show
four months you didn't do so how'd that
feel
oh that's uh yeah I didn't know were you
scared I feel like I have anxiety just
thinking about not doing stand-up for
that long yeah I get if I go to nights
I'm like [ __ ] I'll get nervous on you
same work but on the same way if I go a
week it's like without that's crazy I
might my longest time before this was
eight days
yeah sure did once and then I think
after that's five days off in 17 years
yeah so yeah first it's maybe second
night in Yangon I went to a bar he said
open mic night on Tuesday and I was like
well she was like we thought it was
Thursday I was like I'm still [ __ ]
lonely I can come back here and I know I
can find comedians yeah I could talk to
them that and then I went to one show
and good normal people yeah good quality
now at once
he was like I'd rather hang out with
[ __ ] awful comics telling talk about
me talking stories about [ __ ] going
to Tijuana whorehouses and my wife's
friends you know it's true yeah the
civilians dude yeah so I went to one
shown on pen they asked me if I want to
go up you went watched watch did they
know you're a comedian did they know you
I knew one of the guys who's performing
I saw and I was like oh hey yeah some
guy from then I met in in Bangkok couple
years before we're in that show
William Childress and then it was like
they're like going like [ __ ] no I'm not
sitting with a bomb on my shoulders for
next two months oh we got a bomb for you
right now
[Laughter]
so wait so you went there you didn't go
up no it goes everyone what language are
they speaking in English expat some
other and then other like Danish people
and German people they just go to
English if they want to connect with
others that don't speak German they like
that's art that's the universal language
we're lucky and unlucky that way yeah so
you were like nah don't want to get up I
just want to be away from it it's cool
we drink one of those [ __ ] you know
those beer things but they have a little
tap for you yeah I do what are those
called the only time I've ever had one
that's not a flight the only time I ever
had one was at your freaking the Tilted
Kilt in Maryland
and people were getting those but you
know was the most hilarious thing I was
with this other guy and
like grupa like businessmen they got one
so it's like it you're almost like at
your own cake yeah and they're at the
bar drinking that at the bar at the bar
and he goes why would you ever get that
at the bar I mean you get that for your
table like one more please yeah you
don't have to there's a sushi spot in
the valley it has it looks like one of
those old wooden barrels with the metal
bands around it you know what I mean and
it just has a tap right on the side and
just plop it on your table when you sit
and it's sake big man no it'll be here
oh really
yeah do you just have that for you it's
like right remember party balls
yeah those the size of one of those
apart all the quarter Coors late made a
party ball we used to get the party ball
all the time
those are great yeah well I think they
make those anymore do they
I don't I mean it was a lot of time you
got like we were doing an ATC live
podcast actually I was with Bill burr
and he saw the mic like hit my lips he
goes it just touched your lips I he's
like why you do it somebody else has to
come on use it I go it's Simone next
anyway what you want me to do so I wiped
it all off and hear your [ __ ] that was
that sounded way that did Salwa and not
sound like that we got to change that
sock when it changed my underwear me
give yourself pinkeye it might smell so
bad yesterday by the end and it was
before what do though I just switches my
couch smells awful oh really yeah might
been smelling breath now that I think
about it spread that please yeah all
right you guys ever do anything like
that would you ever like go out stay in
hostels and by the way houses are
cheaper but the main reason I did it so
I could meet other people I mean I love
the idea you know like I think something
that like you know which might come back
to you're special but like the advantage
you have like for us with kids yeah
there's like this like I told you I was
telling you off Michael like I've always
always always wanted to like hop trains
like hobo yeah go cross country I read
this book called
I think it's uh travelling nowhere and
it was like this there's this guy I
can't remember his name but he wrote
this this book about his going from
junior to senior in college he went in
hop trains all cross-country and that
was his senior thesis at Amherst he
wrote this book and then he I read a
second book where he posed he went to
Mexico imposes a Mexican and then with
other Mexicans got a coyote to take him
over the border Wow
he went over the border and then he went
picking he would picking oranges in
California there was a Mexican as a
Mexican and then was picking in Colorado
and then went to Florida then he went
and got a job as a security guard in
sing-sing
and he brought that book called New Jack
and he wrote that book and that was like
the book that kind of blew him up but
coyote and then rolling nowhere was the
first one to and that's it cool and like
you know I used to love like Kerouac and
Ginsberg and Barros I used to read that
was like my [ __ ] and so like yeah the
idea of doing that like I think about
them like well maybe when Reid is like
14 I'm like me and you let's go let's go
hop train that's what I do that but you
know it's dangerous and it's risky risky
but I saw found these out there yeah
travel it's like little kids yeah at 14
if he's around he could handle it
they're adults they are at 14 in ninth
grade I felt like I can handle anything
in my grade you're stronger than most
older pretty strong yeah yeah and lift
stuff you're ready to [ __ ] do it
if you can appreciate it's a different
story yeah right that's something you
look back on probably yeah that's
something you want to be able to do I
went to tour those uh that the tunnels
the Gucci tunnels whatever that
Vietnamese [ __ ] kid hid from the
Americans you know popped up and [ __ ]
fired him Adam yeah climb to the Tonys
pretty cool really yeah it's pretty cool
they show you how they they built these
booby traps where just be like grass on
thing and they were just open up and
then just spikes they want to demoralize
the Americans not just be dead by bullet
it's gonna be bad you're gonna be down
there for a while
[ __ ] the falls out of trees [ __ ] slam
I mean what's that like just standing in
places where like men fought for our
country and died yeah that were definite
not fighting for our country well you
know what I mean like there were fellow
American over there doctors in you
connect to it anytime you have like a
historical place I
you guys got I get it looks like wow
something happened here yeah I feel that
energy yeah feel an energy like we used
to go to Gettysburg I would feel a weird
feeling up there bunch of people died in
this field on that field in that field
like that the Arlington forever where
the the men are buried there but they
didn't with it at all or die they go to
Gettysburg and it's just thousands of
deaths on that grass right there well
the guys got a bayonet in his stomach
100 [ __ ] 200 years ago but so
afterwards we do this long thing it's
pretty interesting there's a family
there with these two small kids the boys
probably like seven six something like
that and I saw a branch with a the leaf
on the end of it and I saw a cat so I
took this branch I just let the cat play
with it you know and uh and the kids
started like how cool and he started
doing it too and I figured like in ten
years if his father's like remember be
anonymous oh yeah but that cats right of
course all he's gonna remember you but I
know it's those little tiny things like
you know what's funny is like I we went
on a family vacation you know I don't
know like a month and a half ago we had
no TV oh no technology right and every
day we'd raise a flag like we had a
flagpole really every day we'd raise the
flag every day we take it down we went
to a 24-hour farm stand that was like
honor system you just you weigh your
food and then you pay and like I was
taking my son and I bet you twice a week
he mentions Bolinas like let's go back
to Bolinas and like yeah we flew kites
we did like on things unfit member on
family vacation you would do things you
don't do normally and you're doing it
with your it becomes like these little
like we had so many little stories and
our family growing up that came from
family vacations and that little thing
playing with that cat you know what I
mean like we've had it all back there on
the road you know and to this day rigo's
remember that tractor I mean he won't
remember when he's seven but so I have a
different theory about remembering these
days because now and I watch it happen
with my daughter I like I remember stuff
back to early as for your memories crazy
I'm when my mom came out I walked her
through the house your mom coming out of
the womb no cause i
they said they said I read something
recently about people who do remember
being born I don't buy that read that no
way no way I agree but I remember being
4 I met my first steps in our house in
my walk though we live we lived in
Houston for about a year we Maryland and
went there for a year and then came back
but I walked my mom mentally through the
home and she was like I said we had
Ronald McDonald curtains and bed sheets
and she's like oh my god you did I was
like I I slept through thunderstorms the
first time there I learned to swim and
climb trees there I remember that at
four and five but I think these days
that kids with the with the readiness of
a video except for your phone with the
radius of a video they're gonna watch
their memory so early on that I think
they're gonna go back to that and
remember things earlier than four and
you know maybe that means maybe like on
that trip they're watching videos
instead of [ __ ] look around the
window right and then they won't even be
having memories they'll just be
remembering memory facebooking Vietnam
that was a good time the same way
sometimes you look in an old picture
like I remember that what you really
remember is that photo you're right that
time it's nice though that you have sort
of sort of something to take you back
there right yeah new home smell the
smell a narrator that's the one thing
about technology now I wish existed back
then and I could go look at the three
year old me just dancing in front
whatever the [ __ ] it was playing kicking
a soccer ball in the house or so I'm
gonna be awesome look what the [ __ ] what
that dude but I I think that like we
only think that because we have it now
whereas it used to just be a memory
actually just existed as a memory yeah
yeah we don't take a picture we don't
water at the time we're just enjoying
yeah don't take a video but we hadn't we
have the old home videos where you you
know before you convert them to DVD I
don't get the projector and real real
and which was cool they're cool to watch
and about you look at that [ __ ] honey I
got one up on our wall at home projector
no the film my grandfather used to have
a reel-to-reel in his basement oh wow
and he had like a little room with the
window in it that he'd open so he'd have
the lights on smoking cigarettes and
he'd be playing a real areal of Star
Wars and the back wall the basement he
just be in his like workshop smoking but
slightly I'm probably having a whiskey
Wow
and we would watch Star Wars and [ __ ]
that's cool did you do anything like
that like go to movies yeah a movie and
me Mr Betty I saw the water mama from
the Train
[Laughter]
sapphire by MTV they just got Dallas
they're loving it hey no ruin is fun
they're like wait you're American who do
shots they are gonna give me the scoop
at next season yeah
they they eat like crazy at movie
theaters they're in the theater the
sound of equality from everybody the
door creaks open every time something
comes in and out people go there to
sleep together and make out and just eat
it's all Kel corn instead a real popcorn
it's all kettle corn you mean like with
like caramel uh no no whatever no kettle
corn kettle corn is like sugar and sugar
instead of salt okay yeah and uh it was
kind of shitty movie but like it was
cool inside like would you like that no
it was in English and then subtitles for
that what was it
Sasson screw it really was assassin yeah
yeah and then I would these Australian
girls who went taught me the term bushed
off what's that mean
[ __ ] stomp in the [ __ ] outdoors it
means a festival in the bush alright so
to put two questions one did you get
laid yeah quick question and and one did
you also get laid without paying for it
good great questions the last time I
went to Thailand
I got a hooker this was three years ago
and I'm like this is my last hope I'm
done why gross it leaves you with his
gross feeling and it's not like I've
never gotten laid if I was a virgin like
cool let's get it over with it's just
like well you can't they're hooker you
sound like you're can't go down on them
yeah you came in I could kiss them you
know you don't want you definitely can't
choke them they'll get upset like a
regular just took out four Pete took
your wives ever
like let her know your control I had a
girl one time I dated it was so into the
choking thing and it just it's scared I
did it but it scared the [ __ ] out of me
cuz she my whole thing was you could die
and it doesn't matter that you were okay
with this my fingerprints hands
everything on your neck and you're dead
I'm going to [ __ ] jail and she had me
do it one time and I was I really was a
[ __ ] about it but I gave it a little
bit and her eyes rolled back a little
bit and I just stopped oh I'll [ __ ] that
I'm not the eyes well back in ecstasy
yeah now no all I saw was [ __ ] twenty
years in a Baltimore [ __ ]
penitentiary yeah no [ __ ] text
evidence all right so you that was the
last time I said the last time yeah and
then and then it got weird okay so after
I got laid probably two days before I
left and then like after like a week or
so I start getting more you left wait
here on the US yeah oh York and there's
circuiting hornier and hornier all
through me and Mark didn't get laid and
then by the end of me amuro's I got a
[ __ ] I got a [ __ ] I got a [ __ ] and then
my next stop was just checking my
Thailand on the way to Laos we're just
gonna take a flight there then take a
land crossing a Laos and then I was like
I got a [ __ ] and they're all there and
Thailand it is readily available yeah
you got to look down and make sure but
like there's so many hookers and they're
pretty hot uh but I was their exotic
sort of - you know Burmese women are the
some of the ugliest in the world I say
some of sorry Burmese bigger out of
Burmese van Oh gross I mean they look
good at 11:00 and then at 12:00 over 70
what a difference a year makes
yeah yeah is my birthday in Thailand it
was like no hooker no don't do it don't
do it and then I'm like maybe oh well I
got a massage and another massage and
where do you go to so that's what I was
gonna ask you go to a massage place to
get the hooker some of them but yeah
yeah they'll give you like a 20-second
massage then like start sucking you know
you hear Pete Holmes story when he was
in Amsterdam and just wanted a massage
yeah it's so fun Oh were they like I
could only a bad they tried to like and
then he's like nah no I don't want that
and he goes and then it just turned into
the worst where she was like like yeah
yeah I got one of those somewhere and I
was like this the mistake she was a bad
and so I thought it was a legit one
there's a bad massage and then
afterwards like all right nice I set up
Shores know calm down calm down she put
her hand on my leg like that and I was
like oh [ __ ] I just kept looking at me
and it's like she was gross it's like
gonna happen not that certainly the next
day after I said I'm not [ __ ] a hooker
when I was so close
[ __ ] a backpacker so I managed to stay
away from me oh so you got a you got a
civilian yeah got a civilian New Zealand
stripper why I'm with that that was the
next stop Thailand was just going to
Thailand to Chiang Mai's in northern
city I didn't go through Bangkok it's
gross why is Bangkok roadside her just
like dirty yeah so dirty it's like
electricity isn't it like them it's just
like people that like people everywhere
but like look like eight-year-olds
selling you should 3m yeah yeah like why
aren't you in school or bed yeah sure
school with three a good point and
there's like so you just passing through
Vietnam pass the toilet and then I got
distracted in Thailand stated in like
two weeks I'm just gonna go there for a
day and I get to the board now is there
is there other stuff like is there like
I'm not saying like symphonies or stuff
like that but were you going out to any
like local culture yeah there's puppet
shows in Myanmar they're really booking
a puppetry didn't see that saw a [ __ ]
show in Thailand uh-huh
like a musical revue which is pretty fun
yeah dude I went to a drag show my
brother and in Provincetown and my
brother's like dude it's not gonna be
what you think drag is and I was like
all right it's all about it's so fun
right dude
it was this guy or this woman it's
raining and man no I can go crazy with
dancing well she was [ __ ] hilarious
it was more stand-up than it was like
that's why my brother's like he goes
it's not really it's not like what you
think a drag show is gonna be yeah she
was dolled up but she was like a
construction worker dolled up and was
funny as F and I was like dude this is
like one of the greatest thing
scene yeah anyway with that so you went
to a show like that oh yeah like that
what's your Oh Thai kickboxing it's
about that yes my favorite underground
[ __ ] no it's all aboveboard aboveboard
what's that that the arms I love board
yeah I've never heard about board that's
right I like it I'm gonna use it
learning with all right because theme
song for learning yeah it's great you
can gamble a little bit people come by
like which one do you want but there's
no like odds are lying you know I don't
know the really big one and like bad now
we're just gonna give it to small
whatever on a bet
oh really yeah but girls fight I'm hey I
mean there's a couple knockouts and a
lot of throws it's great and they play
this weird musical intro with the whole
time yeah there's a guy in charge of
playing they danced beforehand to their
own yeah those psychic mozzie bites are
[ __ ] great I went to one of those
alone yeah just fun times drink beers
drink Chang's just [ __ ] go for it
kill her yeah what's the scariest moment
you've had you had during the four
months there was a you ever feel
threatened you ever feel not no danger
threat I felt was sociological in my
mind because they look like others yeah
I got to me and Martha Oh everyone's
gonna [ __ ] Rob oh it's get away no
I'm understand I should and then I
realized later Myanmar it has it's all
Buddhist and it's like it's part of
their culture to help people Thailand
they'll try to get over on you but in
Myanmar not so I'm like I'm worried
about these people trying to rob me and
one guy was like he was like hey can I
uh
you guys look lost you need help like
what do you need goes well okay you got
me I I was trying to work on my English
[Laughter]
where did you carry your wallet
sometimes just in front pocket yeah yeah
I just really didn't worry about
pickpockets when I was traveling along I
head up my money belt you know for under
your shirt for like all my cash is there
but
it wouldn't work I got nervous a little
in towards the end I made it to East
Timor I went anyway I met a guy yeah I
need fun girl I met a guy to Indonesia
how deep to eat to go easties Timor i'll
deep to go or west East Timor
so this is Timor Leste I say the line
there and then it goes like this there's
a thorough than there shot go island
reserve here I got on a fishing boat
here Jesus ten bucks over to this Jocko
Island the easternmost part of it and as
I'm like walking those last steps to
like hail at fishermen I'm thinking my
[ __ ] captain brothers advice like
don't go past and say you are here on
that on that moped trip over there when
I saw other people at home it you like
hired a moped yeah I got a moped and
just [ __ ] go right now yeah so you
rode a moped to the boat through the
[ __ ] whole way over to down what's it
like what's the Ronettes the roads are
the worst in the way you're riding
through that what your brother said is
the dangerous part on a [ __ ]
moped yeah Jesus Christ well I was in
Bali I met this guy from Jakarta who was
born there but he worked for Facebook in
San Francisco for a while spoke really
good English and she's me spoke really
well English that way and I was like
yeah I want to go to these Timur but it
doesn't it goes well because it's not
dangerous I'm like yeah that's not what
people said he goes that's just a
[ __ ] because they want to trade with
America so they keep the travel advisory
there he goes that's that shit's all
settled in 2006 and I like really goes
yeah where is this now he's team work
this is in Bali in Indonesia so like
gotcha
so like this East Timor Bali's like
there okay bunch of islands over and uh
and I was like really goes yeah and on
the way it goes go to [ __ ] Komodo
Island go see the Komodo dragons and it
was like oh that's here oh for sure
Island and those [ __ ] thing yeah
do not make noise that's got to be like
one of the last alligators Komodo
dragons and birds they got to be it yeah
I feel like I left from the dinosaur era
their tail de head there were the length
of this for this room and that intact
very gift that what do they do they
killed a kid like a couple months before
really a kid but it might have been like
a 20 year old who was staying with
everybody at the watering hole and then
went off to pee by himself and they [ __ ]
it
nothing like Gators like that yeah they
see you alone they go for it
named that don't they have a forked
tongue big split fork there they'd smell
with your tongue yeah all the bacteria
comes out we found we couldn't find him
on the trail and our tour guides reel
into it he goes let's come looking for
him go [ __ ] find some other hackers
we're like yeah fast can they run not
that fast and they were already in
Kalama today give it to me in kilometers
an hour
I think only like one or two I don't
think they run really they walk they
walk and when it's time to rip a [ __ ]
boar apart they rip a boar apart yeah
yeah we just chased him down to the
brush and [ __ ]
I'm all set yeah but was it dope when
you saw me like oh this is worth it yeah
I touched the tail of one and the tour
goes like what what did you talk about
because you get close and he's like he
has this weird stick with to the Y at
the top and I supposed to drive him off
they don't like it um and uh I was like
you never touched my how long you worked
there's like seven years no I've never
touched a komodo dragon you [ __ ] nuts
you like the [ __ ] suppose you've missed
out how long do you stay on that island
used Emoto just that day it was on a
three day I met some dudes on a ferry an
Italian guy and a guy from Belgium and
they were gonna
charter a boat like you want to join in
like yeah so when you meet these guys is
it because you're like oh I know that
dudes backpack and they know I'm back
and then you show up and go hey what's
up guys yeah that's it's just that easy
you see a white guy on a ferry with all
locals on a [ __ ] 18-hour ferry and
you see any of the white person there's
six of them of the eight hundred people
on the ferry
you know like hopefully you speak
English yeah cuz none of these people do
right and then if you do like where he
coming from where'd you go you dropped
eight stories and you went to that oh I
want to go to that how is that gonna be
cool
these guys were chartering a boat join
us I don't know and then an hour later
like what am I even thinking yeah for
sure I'll come with you and where were
they
- they went to komodo they went to the
other Island with the Komodo dragons on
it rin-chan island and they just went to
these snorkel spots we swam with [ __ ]
giant manta rays Wow there's a place we
can jump off and there they're just like
cleaning themselves you just [ __ ] as
hard as you can against the current
Restatement and they're as big as this
room - and you're right these things are
monster god that was [ __ ] amazing you
just jump in you look look for stars you
can try to look at them they're just
gracefully and they like when they're
gone like [ __ ] and you looked at another
one's coming right underneath you neck
[ __ ] you started swimming again heavy
current man that was a great great trip
yeah that was that was that three day
thing was like those guys were great I
didn't some I thought Italian girl she
was like y'all join you how many of
these people were off the grid for this
trip none no one they all had
smartphones they all came in Texas when
you get to you so right there you could
have used their phone if they were at
the cool with it okay so for pictures I
heard though she emailed to me please I
started a new email address for people I
met there so I could check in my new
it's like hey alright so you at least
have some somebody's in contact with the
people I meet right but you've got some
record for yourself later when you're
older of a photo of you there some were
with me like a digital camera
someone told me that like you were
randomly like people who randomly get
like a email from an address they didn't
know it was like a picture of you and
like were you doing that like having
people send it to like that's what it
was I feel like Abram said you would
have someone send a picture maybe it was
the email that you had gave them the
password I needed I had to pay off a bet
on up for it with on punch-drunk
on whose team would go further in the
playoffs it was triple e had the Raiders
it was actually a good year for us Tebow
had the Falcons and and I had the
Cowboys and I thought was my father
loser had to wear a Hitler mustache for
two days and I was in northern Myanmar
when it happened and I'm like I pay off
my bet yeah oh my god I woulda got in so
much trouble you would have done it was
that just blatant is common to ask
[Laughter]
God his breathing by the way nobody
[ __ ] in in in hostile dorms more than
German dudes
really oh they bring them back it's been
three weeks I haven't gotten laid in
their [ __ ] rocking the bunk bed right
on top of yours [ __ ] go to the
showers yeah
did you watch like the Super Bowl over
there I watch it on you know how like
you have that the game cast on ESPN or
if you hold on to refresh it'll refresh
the next play oh yeah can't see it just
see what I did that in in before this
like three day hike all night on a
[ __ ] shittiest Wi-Fi in the world
does keep refreshing the Cowboys Packers
game so anyway I lost so I this guy the
travel is like hey you got Twitter and
he's like no and the other guys like you
got Twitter goes yeah goes I don't use
it throwback that's fine I need you to
tweet a picture help me with the stupid
[ __ ] mustache to this guy Jason Tebow
I did it two days in a row and then
[ __ ] shaved it yeah I got it's awful
there's a picture of it on my Instagram
actually cuz I got took a picture of who
we would use [ __ ] burmese man but
otherwise no no real can't let er - yeah
send a letter to Diaz he was like I mean
know you're safe old school letter
school letter one's gonna be there like
two weeks my I'll be your mail notes
from where and how do you even [ __ ]
do that over you asked me where's the
post office and you go you tell them
where it's going and it's like you just
try you just try to work through it I
gotta put out of here how much he got
your letter it may have a letter mm-hmm
how long did it take a couple weeks
weeks
I think damn there was one I I bought it
[ __ ] up I bought a couple like
souvenirs in Myanmar I'm like what am I
gonna carry this around or a space
became an issue yeah like every times we
want to buy it's like well that means I
gotta jettison something yeah cuz I just
don't have room so uh so I had these
souvenirs this ball is chin long ball a
[ __ ] pipe I bought and something else
but something else whatever it was and I
was like I got a mail his home and they
were like yeah we can get there in two
weeks for this much money I'm like well
I don't need it in two weeks do this
before if you need it yeah and they were
like I'm moving together in a month I'm
like yeah sure let's do that I was like
you have any slower than that like we
have three and a half months like yes
that's what I want
were they storing it cost more to store
it
you'll know the tides three and a half
months yeah it showed up like a week
after I got home really yeah oh yeah
nice present for myself the last time I
was to write my buddy hiked the
Appalachian Trail from Google straight
up five months like did the whole thing
straight and we penpal the whole time
and what I would do is I'd write him a
letter and I put extra paper in with a
like a golf pencil so then he'd get it
because that way he'd have to carry
anything he could get it he can rewrite
and he could then we would just like
take the paper and then flip it over so
he kept I have him all out and then like
you know he had a pencil and then you
know he would tell me like I'm gonna be
here so I'd send it to that post office
and then he'd send it back to me and
then like tell me where he'd be next and
then like you know we'd keep doing it
like though that was kind of cool that
sounds fine missiles I think
letter-writing is like such a cool thing
that just doesn't happen anymore
Robert I was think about this recent the
problem of Texas you you get a text or
you send the text somebody there
immediately like text me back text me
back you got like one to two minutes and
it's like what the [ __ ]
and yeah days past like what the [ __ ]
man yeah normally and it's like you know
damn well that you might have gotten
seven texts at some point and be like I
gotta get back to that before so I gotta
handle this then you get a phone call
when you forget yeah it happens but you
still blame everybody else fourth letter
writing write the letter it's gonna take
five or six days to get there yeah and
then they're gonna read it and then
write a new letter in a day or to send
it back and so you're here for them
again in like 12 days yeah it's great if
they take the time yeah you know cuz if
we all think like oh I don't at the time
I don't have the time to write this yeah
then you missed them you want that
letter cool yes uh she was a girl cycle
yeah I used the pen pal in college I
should get one going again would you do
this again or are you going to do this
again for sure for where where do you
want to go next
I'll tell South America South America is
for sure on the list it's cheap it's
summer when we're winter so I can like
stay I hate the winter so I can stay
warm yeah you don't skip it I got
learn to Spanish so it for East Timor I
met this I don't think you need to learn
Spanish that for everyone else around
the world we're the ignorant ones they
all probably speak enough English South
America it's a rural yeah you put your
own about that the villages yeah all
that [ __ ] yeah it's just nice to have a
rudimentary how does a China standing
yeah you know oh you want to tell me I
[Laughter]
guess at the same time you're gonna
learn learning the language is just
gonna be just another step in you like
why you do this yeah you know oh yeah
exactly so I got like uh before I went
to East Timor one of the Italian second
Italian on that on that boat ride this
girl bra we sent her a letter so she was
off to Indonesia she was like real she
like learn the language
she knew bahasa well and if you had to
like get a bus I don't know we should
get it but she was like move away and
then she was like converse with these
people she was like she was been going
on for five years haven't been I've been
traveling for 5km not no home baby
this move for five years five and a half
yes she would at some point she like
picked oranges in Sydney for [ __ ] six
months yeah
or it's like that's a home base but it's
not her home base right and then trying
to move on so that got my head when I
was going over she 3031 yeah when I got
to eat on the way to East Timor I'm like
I'm getting this [ __ ] dictionary I'm
learning some tattoo and I'm just gonna
get by yeah and so I did it was great
maybe so much easier and I learn more
words off those you know this is so
simple like 3040 words yeah I want to do
better than that with Spanish or another
language another place I want to go you
don't want to tell anyone yeah but you
know what you know I know are you yeah
sure I know I was going some lady told
me like day three or something my last
night in Yangon day four she was they
tell you where I was like oh yeah that
sounds great
yeah yeah man Cambodia was cool
it's all cool of course I'm gonna go
again yeah it's so relaxing but you're
gonna be single so why wouldn't you go
again
what a boring thing did not but even
okay I told my friend Ryan Moran you
don't have course oh no Ryan Moran yeah
okay great so he went on vacation with
his wife and I was like hey man I did
before I even left I was like if you
really want to enjoy yourselves leave
your phones at home get burner phones
when you get there so you can converse
with each other they don't have kids and
then just really be away from work yeah
and he's like yeah maybe and then he
came back he was like I should have
because work kept coming out [ __ ] yeah
yeah you know it's like well I'm not
gonna do anything but I'll check it yeah
it was just so relaxing
no responders drop when he said yeah I
felt it when I got back I didn't know
why I was loving it so much then I got
back but like okay we need you to do
this and this I'm like what even that
much were comics yeah how much but zero
responsible I just get annoyed like I
don't want to send that [ __ ] email
yeah yeah so there was nothing to do
great oh man it was great well speaking
of great this episode has been great
we're there Ari you know we don't do
three hours you know okay this has been
[ __ ] great man how long do you think
it's been o'clock over an hour right
it's definitely over now hour and 10
hour ten yes right in that pocket
hey for real thank you for coming back
on here as always it's a pleasure and uh
we'll be at the ATC festival with you
but why don't you one more time just
promote whatever you want your special
especial on Netflix called double
negative you can watch half of it now
half it later
some people say adulthood is their
favorite some people say children a
children is more like you can see the
through line throughout adulthood is
more just bits but like I don't know
which watch it when you want to share it
with your friends awesome yeah for sure
forever check it out and have a podcast
about skip to think that sick who's
gonna be on very soon I can't wait yeah
great to have you on man thanks for
coming by as always Jay Larson comic con
Jay Larson comedy on all social media
Ryan Sickler comm Ryan Sickler on all
social media we'll talk to y'all next
Tuesday